It's super easy to clean the inside of the boiler.
You just lift it up.
Then I'm gonna take the pan that I had the bacon on,
and this is. The bacon grease is all settled in here,
so I'm gonna clean this out.
Inside here is all enamel,
so you just wipe this out with a rag.
And then there's a little grease patch here,
which I cooked some fried potatoes last night,
so some of them fell down inside here.
So you can cook here in the bottom of the grill
and then on top of the broiler at the same time
on this hot plate.
The top of the umbrella also comes off to clean it.
But the more you clean it,
the less, um,
nonstick it is.
So I do. This is not as clean as I like it to look,
but the more seasoning builds up,
the less things stick to it.
So I can fry some eggs on here just fine right now,
because it does have a little bit of build up of seasoning,
but it has been,
you know, scrub down with soapy water.